all right so first for a quick show of
hands who actually has heard of reason
ml okay actually most of the room who
but who is actually skeptical about
reason ml actually still a lot of people
that's great so this talk is for you
then and I'm glad to see some healthy
skepticism so I'm Eric and I'm a
front-end engineer working on JavaScript
applications at I am here in Berlin and
in earlier days I worked on social
network and streaming platforms and have
had many opportunities to be skeptical
about pulling in fancy new technologies
or languages but before I dive into what
reason is I'd like to set the scene a
bit for why I prepared this talk today
so I have a problem and the problem
comes from working on a large JavaScript
application at ion and we use an error
reporting service to track the kinds of
users that real people experience in
their browsers and sadly it worked
really well so if you do something like
sentry or roll bar and you might have
hundreds of thousands or even millions
of users you what you're in for a rude
surprise about what kinds of errors
people experience in browsers if they
have extensions on their browsers it can
interfere with your app the list goes on
so but one kind of rare error in general
rains is king and I think you might
share the same problem yeah so uncaught
type error cannot read property of
undefined and it's no surprise either in
fact some data collected by rollbar
suggests that this is the number one
JavaScript error in the wild and let's
check out some research they actually
compiled about this so they process data
on a little over a thousand projects and
published the top 10 errors in Java
Script projects and our little error is
unsurprisingly number 1 and you notice a
little trend in this list yeah 7 out of
10 of these errors are type errors and
even number 10 actually is somewhat of a
type error so this thing isn't just my
problem
it's actually all of our problem so
actually what can be done about it
remember the context I mentioned earlier
this relatively large application that I
work on at I am
it's a react app and with that in the
back of it back of your mind I'd like to
finally circle back and explain let his
reason ml I still haven't told you
so I'd characterize it simply like this
reason is a way to write safer react
apps that don't crash and I'd like to
say even more broadly it's a way to
write safer software that doesn't crash
this is an appealing proposition for
JavaScript developers these days like
just look at the success of typescript
in the last couple of years we're
looking for a way we're hungry for a way
to write resilient apps for the web so
react as part of the language and
considered in its design it has
first-class JSX support Jordan Wolk who
created both react and reason gave a
great talk about this just last month I
believe and in fact it was his first
talked since the renouncing react in
2013 it's called react to the future and
it's very worth watching I highly
recommend it and it but it goes through
the history of like how reactive olve so
just how similar then does reason react
and javascript react look so really
quickly here's a react component written
in reason it's a very familiar syntax
there's a react component annotation at
the top which just helps our compiler
understand all the type information
related to any react component stuff
synthetic events hook signatures
everything and labeled arguments can be
passed in any order with a tilde this is
a language feature I think that Python
has as well but it's a very useful thing
for developer ergonomics and they accept
default values too it's familiar enough
if you come from an es 6 kind of
background
and here's the JavaScript equivalent so
it's really no joke that reacted is part
of the language like in our JavaScript
example we would need a babble plug-in
to transform the JSX with reott with
reason JSX is just part of the language
so how many more similarities actually
can we expect well the answer is a lot
just a moment and that's because the
future of react is being made the reason
and let's walk through a little history
of something that we're all familiar
with now so September 1st 2017 reducer
components right now it's announced on
the reason react blog and we see the
terminology of effects being used in
react and things like update with side
effect and side effects in October 26
2018 like a little over a year later
hooks are announced at react conf so and
then we see things like use reducer use
effect seems familiar right the concepts
are now mainstream class components for
example are all but deprecated and
reason react in JavaScript react this is
the clear definition that the core team
has told people to take as well this is
reason guiding its users to the future
of writing react so but what if you're
not writing react this is the survey of
about 20,000 JavaScript developers it
comes out every year it's open for this
year by the way if you want to submit
your own opinions about developing
JavaScript but if you work on a
medium-sized to large web application it
means you're probably reaching for one
of these frameworks right but every
single one of these depends on a few
things like a build system libraries to
help with state management usually
libraries to help with immutability if
you really care about performance and
predictability in your application so I
would think there's actually another
good point that I would say frames
reason ml which has nothing to do with
react actually and that's reason ml is
one coherent platform with a fast
compiler
so one coherent platform there's no need
for Babel because the language itself is
extensible there's a language feature
called PP X's which is like babble but
built into the language also immutable
data structures are built into the
language which means you don't need
libraries to do this there's an
interesting side effect here which means
we don't need to manually type the data
structures from immutable J s this can
require some real effort and typescript
for example also a reason has its own
formatter which was the inspiration for
prettier it's called ref MT and it was
sort of a prior art before prettier came
along and there's no loaders or webpack
gymnastics to make reason work in your
project so a fast compiler we expect
JavaScript to come out in the end right
if we're writing reasons something has
to compile it so we have a built in
compiler that will take our reason code
and make it run in browsers but just how
fast is it like this is the thing
hanging over the entire question or the
whole point so it looks so fast in fact
that the vs code reason extension can
cold build your entire project on every
save and you don't even notice imagine
webpack trying to do that and I'll come
back to this later since it's a crucial
point for developer productivity
typescript for example suffers from some
serious performance issues on large
projects like part of this is due to the
compiler beaten written in JavaScript
and all type information must be held in
memory and this can lead to some serious
scalability issues but more importantly
there's like compounding effects these
increased build times like business
value attention spans which are short
and for me the killer one which is
context switching it kills my flow
creativity and continuity and for me
anyway along compile times for a large
project with hundreds or thousands of
modules is a reality and reason ml is
inspiring a total rethink of JavaScript
bundling in general there's a project
out there it's in alpha right now called
fast pack and look at some of these
benchmark times compared to web pack and
parcel it's it's crazy I mean it's
orders of magnitude faster fast PAC is
not part of reason amount
it's just a tool written with it and
just an interesting side note about how
reason is affecting the broader issues
of JavaScript bundling right now so
we're mostly JavaScript developers here
and we're used to NPM and lucky for us
reason packages are distributed through
NPM and in fact to begin a new Reason
project that's exactly what we reach for
and we only have to run one command to
get started with a new react project or
plain reason project written in reason
ml this is done with the buckle script
compiler this takes our reason code
outputs JavaScript yeah and yes platform
contains everything we need to generate
a new project skeleton and compiler
reason code also comes with different
scaffold themes so if you do want to
begin with a react project it has a
theme for that if you want to begin with
a vanilla compiles to plain JavaScript
project it can do that as well but let's
start from first principles and then
finally apply these kinds of ideas that
I've been talking about to an existing
project and so it's demo time
all right
good so when you begin a brand new
reason project the folder structure that
you speak to the left is pretty familiar
it looks like a JavaScript project we
even have a package JSON we have some
other configurations that Buckle script
looks for and in our SRC folder here
I've prepared a few demo examples I will
kind of start from first principles like
I said and maybe the best place to start
is by not writing any reason at all
so here's JavaScript code dumped into
reason this is a reason file but it's
wrapped in this nasty looking raw
annotation which lets us if we got stuck
in a project just use plain JavaScript
and then maybe go back and enhance it
with type information later so once this
is compiled it compiles alongside I've
configured Buckle script to compile this
file alongside the reason file into a
BSD J's file and this is what it looks
like it's still pretty readable
JavaScript but let's say we want to
start slowly adding type information to
this plain JavaScript function we can
still dump the contents of that function
into our raw annotation but then define
what we want to call that function
assign what we want what kind of types
the arguments that can be and then in
the end what it returns then when we
actually use this function down here we
have reason inferring all of our type
information about our JavaScript
function because we've annotated it this
is kind of a way to incremental e adopt
reason into a project and when it's
compiled again it's just plain
JavaScript it imports a curry helper to
help this is actually a feature that
lets us use labelled arguments which we
saw earlier but to do that it requires
currying and so that's why we see curry
here
all right but let's say we have another
JavaScript file that sits on its own
this is the more realistic use case we
have an exported multiply function in a
separate file how would we use that in
reason
so with Buckle script we can import that
module as the JavaScript module declare
that it was external tell it tell reason
about the type information about it and
that it's a default export but then we
can actually write reason code based on
the imported module here and if we try
to pass in an argument that does not
match the type signature something like
a string then actually the reason
compiler tells us it's the wrong type so
nothing spectacular here but worth
noting then moving on let's say we don't
want to write any JavaScript anymore
we're gonna start writing pure reason
well here we've declared a type photo
which is called a record and reason it
looks like a JavaScript object and if
used flow or typescript this would seem
pretty familiar to you and when we
actually declare this record down here
and assign it to a variable internally
this is not represented as a Java object
in reason and it's compiled you'll see
what we end up with records are
represented as unwrapped arrays this
might change in Buckle script in the
future but right now this is an
optimization technique that Buckle
script does to more efficiently handle
immutable data structures so instead of
this being a JavaScript object this is
an array with three items and they even
reason even annotates it so you
understand what kind of data structure
it is you're looking at but you wouldn't
want to use something like this in a
JavaScript project but there's a reason
why records were chosen at one point by
Buckle script and it's for speed and I
can show you a little bit of information
about this really quick so here's an
article by Xavier chiavari that kind of
examines why unwrapped arrays are really
useful as are really fast for the
JavaScript engines like v8 and it's
SpiderMonkey to use and this is a
benchmark of operations per second
updating three element records with
object to sign or
slice and these unwrapped arrays that
buckle script uses and the unwrapped
arrays are orders of magnitude faster to
update and this is just the decision
that buckle buckle script decided to
make to represent objects in JavaScript
in a different data structure and this
is a flexible language feature actually
so if we use something like buckle
script it can make optimizing decisions
about how we write our code and cater to
the most recent optimizations that
JavaScript engines can actually do and
that's fantastic so moving along oh
actually one more thing I should note is
that if we want to be able to use this
record in JavaScript we need to somehow
convert it to a data structure that we
actually enjoy using in JavaScript like
objects so here we would have to
annotate this to convert from an
unwrapped array to something that
JavaScript can consume without us
worrying about which index in an array
that we need to access
so if I've annotated this with BS
deriving jeaious converter it actually
automatically generates two new
functions in our file here which is
photo to j s and photo from j s and this
is just to help us with developer
ergonomics if we're gonna start writing
reason modules that need to Interop with
other javascript files out there so yeah
but let's say we don't want to work with
these converter functions and maybe
that's kind of awkward or adds runtime
overhead to our applications there's a
tool out there that is not part of
reason but it's an extension that you
can add to your project called gen type
which makes not only it easier to access
reason records in JavaScript but it also
can generate typescript and flow
information flow types so you don't
break continuity in your project so when
we look at what this photo compiles to
with Gen type you can see I've actually
got a float type here generated and the
value that I've exported has the float
type flow type annotation attached
including direct access to these
different elements of the record without
runtime overhead and this is amazing if
you want to introduce or if you want to
use reason but your team has collect
decided we want to use typescript or
flow you don't have to short-circuit
your type information of your existing
project gen type can add it for you
alright so here's where actually reason
kind of shines sometimes we see these
really nasty nested if statements and of
course you can write them in reason but
there are more powerful tools like this
happens a lot in JavaScript where we
need to sort of derive some kind of
state based on outside information
sometimes we just have to rely on a lot
of if-else statements here I'm trying to
figure out if something as a two-legged
arctic animal and there's a lot of yeah
if statements that kind of go into that
and when it's compiled it looks like
this you know it's nothing special
wouldn't want to read it manually but
here were directly comparing strings
which in JavaScript land like we
wouldn't notice it but in compilers this
is a pretty slow operation in
comparing strings as an ode to the N
problem if we want to have a more
efficient way to match over nested if
statements or if derive some kind of
information about the thing that we're
processing it'd be much more useful to
do something like this so I'm going to
put this side by side next to our nasty
if-else so here instead of declaring
animal and climate as strings I can
declare animal and climate as variants
they look like enums from flow or
typescript if you're familiar with those
but in reason they're a lot more
powerful because they can also be
constructors that act a bit like
functions and they can be pattern
matched again and if you're not familiar
with pattern matching is think of it
like truth tables so you have a set of
conditions you create a truth table and
in the end you just want a true or false
and pattern matching is a really
different tool so here in this switch
statement which looks very similar to
JavaScript instead of switching over one
element you can switch over any number
number of elements but then you have to
also trace that element in each case and
here I have I'm trying to figure out if
it's a two-legged Arctic animal in fact
actually know that all dogs are not
two-legged so I won't have to switch
through Arctic and tropical I can
replace that with an underscore and it's
kind of conflated down but then the like
the real question here is what does this
compile to at the end is it gonna look
anything like what we saw in the
compiled j/s code for the example on the
right
no the compiler has figured out
everything about what we wanted to do
based on our types and pattern matching
we end up with one value here there's no
runtime over it's bonkers it's bananas
ok so let's say we want to apply that
kind of principle like this pattern
matching to something in react
it would look something like this so
here's a reducer component and it looks
very much like JavaScript like in fact
the switch statement here looks exactly
like the kind of switch statement you
would include in any reducer component
but with pattern matching we get
compiler information about if we're
missing a case so if I delete increment
here and save reason has told us we're
mitching we're missing a case increment
and actually JavaScript has a proposal
right now available on TC 39 which you
can review which would add pattern
matching to the language so the feature
of javascript includes pattern matching
but a great way to get started is by
looking at reason all right oh and
actually I had the proposal up here real
quick I'm not going to go into it too
much but this is a really exciting new
language feature I think that would help
JavaScript developers just write better
software but again it's really nice to
see reason having these principles like
first and foremost and driving the
JavaScript community towards better
coding all right so my next example is
like in the end I said I work on this
JavaScript application just how easy is
it to add it to how easy is it add how
easy is it to add reason to an existing
project so I'll pull that up really
quick
all right so just to give an overview of
what we're gonna look at this is like a
real slice of something that I work on
the photos are mine and they're terrible
so please do not judge it was taken with
a plastic camera a long time ago but
there's some functionality in here
that's worth noting and that is whenever
you want to click on one of the filters
here on the left like liked or edits
requested or approved it's gonna change
a token in the URL here and that token
exists is because if you receive a link
to this from slack or an email like from
one of your producers in a project you
need to be able to retain that filter
information and then pass it along to
the UI and then graph QL goes and makes
a request with that token so it's a
basic filter function and I can show you
what that looks like it's kind of often
a little helpers area and it's just a
basic switch statement that returns an
object with a property that's filter and
then the different filter state that
this thing should be in it's a very it's
like a very stilled simple kind of use
case but it'd be interesting to look at
like how this could be rewritten
rewritten in reason and to take
advantage of some of the type safety
that we can gain with reason so here's
that same thing rewritten in reason I
have to import JavaScript constants in a
specific kind of way because they are
still JavaScript strings like there's no
way we can coerce that into some kind of
Reason variant without retaining
information about the string but we can
create polymorphic variants and so these
are just like the variants we saw
earlier but we can attach extra bits to
them so here I'm attaching liked post
production or approved as strings and
but that that gives us information now
in our filter type about not only like
the variant information but then the
JavaScript string that was attached to
that and we can pattern match over this
in the same way that we saw in our
earlier examples and then some running
short on time I'm going to have to power
through this really quick all right
so I'm gonna go back to the slides
and all right so quick to review there's
a pretty clear gradual adoption path for
reason ml tools like Jen type give us
crazy amounts of power to generate or to
leverage existing types from typescript
or flow and also generate generate new
ones and it helps us not break our
continuity in our existing projects and
that's crazy and we only touched the
surface here about the reason language
features it's only 30 minutes like
variants are great pattern matching is
uniquely powerful but I don't even have
time to talk about things like pipe
operators or compiling to other
languages or Oh camel Interop or any of
these like other amazing things that you
don't care about right now but are
amazing and that's for another time when
you're not a skeptic and we saw a
uniquely powerful type system that
integrates effortlessly with our
development tooling the type system is
really what makes the difference here
for me and let me explain we saw some
pretty standard types but they don't
seem fundamentally different from flow
or typescript right keep in mind though
that reasons type system can reflect all
structures that exist in flow and
typescript but the reverse is not true
and that's an insanely powerful concept
to remember and notice we did not see
any any type that's the first thing that
can kill any prototype script or flow
project when working on a team good luck
committing on not using any if you're
using typescript or flow the other thing
is the type system will not change
who here has been burned by type scripts
type system changing yeah at least a few
people so the reason ml type system has
at its essence been around since 1968 or
78 depending on who you ask
the hindley-milner type system it's the
foundation for all the types in the ML
language family and it's battle-tested
and slowly at stop littering your code
base with function annotations like
declare your types be done with it
let the program do the rest reason of
all types are sound meaning that when
compiled they're guaranteed to be
accurate there are some escape hatches
that you need to be mindful of but
mostly this is true and this quality
enabled the creation of even theorem
provers software so it's insanely
powerful
check out Isabella if you're interested
in like that kind of thing so to wrap
things up I started this by mentioning
my problem or like our problem and like
building programs and reason gives us
one path out of this problem
it's not the answer to everything but it
provides a clear path to generally
improving our software like most
problems problems in software
development are not language or tooling
problems they're people and process
problems and like David Nolan gives a
great talk about this - if you ever want
to check that out and we don't need to
break our brains migrating is this
existing code we get to keep our types
from our existing projects but most of
all it's a practical tool for writing
great applications for like real users
out there and so if you find yourself a
little less skeptical skeptical about
reason there's some great ways to get
started like the home page for reason is
a great place to start also there's an
awesome reason ml github list and the
reason ml discord channel is super
helpful at any time of the day
everyone's very friendly there but yeah
thanks
[Applause]
you